what we do to grow a business is the who
the what and the how that's our big
thing so it's like we'll Supply the what
which is the Playbook we'll recruit The
Who and then we'll teach them the house
so we can bring somebody in we can have
our expert be like here's our Playbook
now you go run it and I'm here to to
play defense with you and make sure we
can troubleshoot along the line we just
do that by Department based on whatever
the constraint of the business is and we
do it that way so that the Enterprise
value of the business that we invested
in continues to grow rather than being
dependent on hold code which would
actually make them less valuable